ha sido una mañana en la que volvió la
violencia después de un sábado que había
transcurrido con calma y en un contexto
de tensión por la convergencia de tres
celebraciones religiosas la semana santa
cristiana el pesaje judío y el ramadán
musulmán todo inició cuando parece un
grupo de palestinos arrojó piedras a
buses de visitantes judíos causando
cinco heridos esto provocó y bajo este
argumento que la policía israelí
irrumpir en la explanada de las
mezquitas por segunda vez en tres días
allí resultaron heridas 17 personas
según la media luna roja palestina que
también denunció que las autoridades no
le permitieron ingresar a atender a más
de lastimados mientras que la policía
israelí informó de 18 detenidos
transcurridos esta situación y se ha
despejado la explanada nosotros
estuvimos presentes en el lugar y vimos
como la policía ha realizado cordones
para permitir que visitantes judíos
ingresarán a la explanada algunos de
ellos comenzaron a cantar y a rezar lo
cual es considerado una provocación por
los palestinos y genera este tipo de
estallidos de detención teniendo en
cuenta que es un lugar reserva reservado
para el culto
y que este tipo de restos terminan
siendo los que generan esta violencia de
momento no hay interés o no parece haber
intereses en una escalada violenta pero
este tipo de episodios son los que
pueden generar que la situación se salga
de control